bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
pour la troisième année consécutive le
ski en toi en piste s'installe au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'occasion pour les employeurs et les
candidats de se rencontrer
quels sont les métiers en tension nous
ferons le point avec pôle emploi
côté entreprises comment se préparer
pour mieux leur côté avec l'apec
nous avons deux roues également en
l'emploi des jeunes avec la mission
locale ce qui emploient ou fait tout au
plus
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines rassemble dix
sept mille entreprises sur son
territoire et concentre 145 mille
emplois l'insertion professionnelle
demeure parmi les priorités de
l'agglomération pour la troisième année
consécutive ce qui emploie en piste
s'invite au vélodrome le 27 février
c'est une journée de du recrutement sur
saint quentin en yvelines qui s'adresse
donc à toutes les entreprises du
territoire et qui propose aux demandeurs
d'emploi comme aux salariés en poste qui
souhaite évoluer dans leur dans leur
travail dans leur métier de venir
rencontrer les entreprises pour
éventuellement postuler à des offres
d'emploi
oui ce moteur c'est intéressant pour à
tous et qui n'ont pas de travail je
travaille chez o2 du coup services
d'adel personne donc je recrute moi
aussi les périodes
oui je pense que je vais y aller oui la
levée le noter le 27 au vélodrome avec
un thème cette année
l'emploi de proximité le succès de cette
édition ne se dément pas l'an passé près
de 3000 visiteurs s'étaient rendus au
vélodrome
cinq mille offres d'emploi étaient à
pourvoir 200 entreprises étaient
présentes une sur deux avait recruté
d'autres avaient amorcé un premier
contact les grands groupes comme les
petites entreprises recrutent
[Musique]
installé depuis juillet 2019 sur
coignières car watts est spécialisé dans
le retrofit automobile l'entreprise
transforme les véhicules thermiques en
véhicules électriques
on a un regain d'activité ces dernières
semaines ces derniers mois notamment du
fait de la signature prochaine d'un
décret qui autorisera et qui facilitera
surtout le rétrofit et pour trouver des
candidats car watts recrute à l'estaca
mais pas seulement on a déjà recruté des
jeunes singes et qui sont venus chez
nous on stage et qu'ils sont beaux ces
dons qu'ils sont devenus salariés de
carole white
le deuxième mode de recrutement basse un
mode relativement classique 1 on essaye
de publier des annonces et d'attirer des
candidats c'est pas toujours évident
parce qu'on n'est pas connu et il ya une
réelle pénurie de compétences autour de
ces métiers de l'électronique et de
l'intégration de l'électronique dans les
véhicules les profils qu'on recherche
sont plus des profils qui ont été
confrontés à l'environnement automobile
aujourd'hui on est une petite dizaine et
on espère être une vingtaine à la fin de
l'année on profite de ce speed dating on
va dire pour approcher des gens qui
n'auraient pas eu connaissance de ces
opportunités qui n'ont pas fait de
veille sur internet qui connaissent pas
qu'avant est donc pour l'heure montré un
petit peu la diversité de nos activités
[Musique]
entreprises mais aussi partenaires du
territoire
tout se prépare en vue de l'événement
[Musique]
pôle emploi participe pour sa troisième
année consécutive cette année au niveau
au pôle emploi on s'est beaucoup axé sur
les candidats ça va être les années les
deux années précédentes on avait
beaucoup travaillé avec les entreprises
pour les aider justement à s'approprier
l'événement
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui est
un peu acquis au niveau entreprise donc
on a vraiment centré nos actions sur les
candidats pour les informer mais surtout
pour les préparer plus de 22000 mails
ont été envoyés aux candidats potentiels
des agences pôle emploi de plaisir
trappe et guyancourt
une fois inscrits et demandeurs d'emploi
participe au sein de leur agence à des
ateliers de préparation
ceux ci ont été doublés en vue de
l'événement c'est surtout comment se
présenter là les candidats vont être
directement face à face avec les
employeurs que ce soit sur un stand où
sur un job dating
ils ont quelques minutes pour être
percutant donc on est sur du pitch on
est sûr de la croche en demies métiers
de la vente de la restauration du
bâtiment de l'industrie ou encore des
services à la personne des secteurs en
tension
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas de personnes
immédiatement disponible avec toutes les
compétences demandées par les employeurs
donc on accompagne les employeurs pour
leur présenter des candidats qui vont
avoir soit des compétences des
compétences transférables soit
effectivement des appétences qui vont
les amener à aborder le métier pour
lequel l'entreprise recrute et on les
forme via les mesures pour l'emploi
côté entreprises un accompagnement peut
s'avérer indispensable pour se préparer
au mieux pour le jour j
on a un marché du recrutement qui est
ultra tendu sur les cadres et les
ingénieurs on
aux alentours de 3,2 pour cent de taux
de chômage donc la ressource est
extrêmement pénuriques avare et par
conséquent les entreprises déploient des
trésors d'activité et d'inventivité pour
attirer les candidats se rendre visibles
ils ont pas toujours tout à fait
conscient volontairement ou pas des
tensions du marché il ya ce besoin de
professionnalisation dont cas on
intervient là dessus l'apec sensibilise
les entreprises tout au long de l'année
via des ateliers notamment au sein du
ski cube visibilité travail sur la
marque employeur méthodes de recrutement
réforme de la formation ou encore
qualité de vie au travail
tout ce qui peut rendre l'entreprise
plus attractive vis-à-vis des candidats
certains sont ultra pro ils ont
peut-être pas besoin de du conseil
appelle qui vont utiliser le jobboard la
cvthèque la profil thèque
ils vont revenir à des matinales mais
ils vont être
opérationnel au sens actif sur tous les
champs du recrutement et professionnels
d'autres parce que c'est des pme et des
tpe ou des entreprises qui ont une
croissance rapide pour être plus à la
peine parce que parce que il faut faire
beaucoup de choses à la fois parce que
recruter c'est un métier à part entière
marketing rh technicité des outils
inclusion des managers dans le process
rh rapidité d'action le 27 février
daniel arnould sera aussi au vélodrome
pour faire le tour des stands
entreprises l'emploi des jeunes n'est
pas occulter les acteurs locaux qui
accompagne ce public tout au long de
l'année participeront eux aussi à
l'événement a mis sur cale de 50 à quel
plutôt des jeunes qui sont peu ou pas
qualifiés et comme ils sont jeunes ils
ont aussi peu ou pas du tout
d'expérience et souvent ils se sont pas
tellement poser la question de leur
projet professionnel
plus on a la chance sur 50 ha d'avoir un
bassin économique très dynamique
donc ya pas mal de projets qui peuvent
se réaliser sur 50 ans on peut
considérer que 99% des jeunes s'ils en
ont envie
peuvent trouver une insertion
professionnelle au vélodrome 4
animateurs de la mission locale
accueilleront jeunes et moins jeunes sur
des ateliers seront sur les stands
booster vos compétences conquis
ils animeront des ateliers emploi lettre
de motivation des ateliers pitch pour se
présenter en quelques minutes auprès des
employeurs
et puis ils animeront aussi les ateliers
sur l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
dans le cadre de leurs recherches les
animateurs accompagneront aussi le jeune
public sur les stands employeurs dans le
cadre de dispositifs d'accompagnement
renforcé la garantie jeunes un
dispositif qui permet d'acquérir
compétences et expériences et de
développer des savoir être pour accéder
plus vite à l'emploi d'autres
initiatives pour l'emploi se déroulent
tout au long de l'année parmi lesquels
le pli pour les personnes les plus
éloignées de l'emploi mais aussi
plusieurs journées de job dating pour
répondre aux besoins en recrutement des
entreprises saint-quentinoise en avril
l'agglomération a mis en place son
propre portail d'offres d'emploi on a
notre portail de l'emploi au niveau
local qui est leur emploi point fr qui
permet de poursuivre les phases de
recrutement via le portail internet et
donc la mise en relation se fait aussi
après et avant l'événement via le
portail de l'emploi l'inscription est
gratuite
plus de 13 mille offres d'emplois sont à
pourvoir les postulants peuvent y
télécharger leur cv nous sommes une
start up nous recrutons beaucoup donc en
ce moment nous avons trois annonces
publiées sur le site ce qui est bientôt
une quatrième aussi essentiellement des
postes techniques ingénieurs et
techniciens donc ingénieurs
mécanique ou développement logiciel
plusieurs profils d'ingénieurs et on a
aussi réussi à recruter un poste
d'assistant administratif
grâce à la plateforme de l'esc grecque
il ya des gens qui se servent
de ski en poils qui ont trouvé un emploi
grâce à cette plate forme parce que les
offres d'emploi qu'il ya dessus sont
très diverses et on se sert de ce qui
emploie pour accompagner les jeunes dans
leur recherche d'emploi
un appui supplémentaire pour mieux
préparer la troisième édition du ski
emploi en piste en rendez vous installer
tous les ans au vélodrome
chaque forum avec une opportunité
d'embauché pour pour les demandeurs
d'emploi c'est plusieurs dizaines de
jeunes que nous accompagnons qu'ils vont
trouver un emploi c'est une belle
opportunité pour les entreprises de
s'ouvrir à des candidats qu'il n'aurait
pas rencontré via une diffusion d'offres
et pour les candidats c'est l'occasion
de pouvoir avoir en visu directement des
entreprises qui n'arrive peut-être pas à
contacter via un mail ou via une
candidature et pour ma part oui j'irai à
la rencontre des entreprises en fonction
de la charge
priorité au recrutement mais bon vous
savez désormais tout sur le quai emplois
à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]